president Trump meets today in New York
with a series of world leaders in a
defiant speech before the United Nations
yesterday the president vowed to totally
destroy North Korea if it threatens the
u.s. or its allies he also called the
Iran nuclear deal an embarrassment
Margaret Brennan is at the United
Nations some tough words Margaret indeed
well this morning President Trump is
expected to hold meetings with the king
of Jordan as well as the presidents of
Egypt and the Palestinian Authority to
discuss Mideast peace and combating
terrorism he's also going to have a
one-on-one with UK prime minister
Theresa May who will tell the president
she opposes his plan to try to
renegotiate the Iran nuclear deal major
portions of the world are in conflict
and some in fact are going to hell
president Trump's whirlwind week of
diplomacy brought some very undiplomatic
language the United States has great
strength and patience but if it is
forced to defend itself or its allies we
will have no choice but to totally
destroy North Korea Rocketman is on a
suicide mission for himself and for his
regime before President Trump took the
podium North Korea's UN Ambassador left
the room in protest it's really out of
place when you're talking to the world
leaders in the United Nations former
Secretary of Defense Leon Panetta any
miscalculation any provocative act could
suddenly send us into a war while the
president talked tough he stopped short
of mentioning North Korea's number one
trading partner by name China but hinted
there may be consequences for any
country that supplies the regime mr.
Trump also had harsh words for Iran the
Iranian government masks a corrupt
dictatorship behind the false guise of a
democracy president Trump criticized the
International deal to freeze Iran's
nuclear program which he is considering
withdrawing from that deal is an
embarrassment to the United States and I
don't think you've heard the last of it
last night on colbert former
rival Hillary Clinton said mr. Trump's
tone was beneath the office of the
presidency I thought it was very dark
dangerous not the kind of message that
the leader of the greatest nation in the
world should be delivering the president
responded this morning on Twitter
calling Clinton crooked and accusing her
of allowing North Korea to build nukes
Charlie we will expect the White House
to continue to point to the praise that
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu gave the president saying this
was the most courageous speech that he
has heard in 30 years
Margaret thanks